as of guys my name is in trying to
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we started a little bit of a
code review check out that video if you
haven't already we also fixed a lot of
the issues with the IM GUI viewport and
today we're going to continue doing a
bit of a code review and i also want to
take a look at where we should probably
like what direction we should go in with
the continuation of this series I
thought I'd take it in more of kind of a
live approach and honestly this just
credit this is gravitating towards live
stream at this point but anyway we're
gonna take a look at the code base in
general see what we can do to improve it
and what's really gonna help us with our
whole tree workflow so let's dive into
it I want to the first thing I want to
do is run this because I actually ran it
just before this video and I noticed a
bug if we minimize this
well actually minimizing it seems to
work at this point was it
yeah wind it's a windows key D which is
supposed to show the desktop does
something weird it generates it doesn't
invalid it gives us an invalid value
from OpenGL saying that levels width and
high it must be 1 or greater and the
problem really is that the width and
height of the viewport is just not it's
not above a zero and we can we can
further look at this by just saying okay
sorry it is above zero but it looks like
the height is a huge value I'm not
really sure what's going on here that
looks like it's just negative 1 being
expressed as an unsigned int so I'm not
sure why this was reported as a negative
number yeah you can see here that the
viewports and panel sizes is negative 6
so it is a negative value that's being
cast into an unsigned integer and then
like obviously getting something that is
completely unusable so what we need to
do and I'm not sure why it's possible to
actually query the available content
region from iron GUI and get a negative
value as a response that's very odd I'm
not sure how it calculates this okay so
it actually did that's probably where
it's coming from so de seekers a
position from the from the contacts from
the device context or whatever that is
draw context and that just seems to be
completely wrong so
honestly that's really weird the fact
that it's happening and you saw that
Windows key did come through them how
should we fix that I mean we can do a
very primitive check here to make sure
that if it's less than zero we just
clamp it to zero but more so what should
happen is well if we try and resize a
frame buffer and the frame buffer resize
which is what happens here is outside of
a certain range which probably either
assert or just refuse to do it so that
this can happen when we try to maybe
resize it with zero zero being invalid
so then we just we basically just should
just not do the resize until we get a
valid value because doing the resizes
it's not something that we you know we
shouldn't be doing that and it's totally
fine to do that because remember
resizing resizing is actually an extra
operation it's not like we're doing
something to make it work it's more or
less like hey the size has changed to
recreate everything so by not doing it
you know we'll be doing less things
instead of doing unnecessary things
which i think is is probably important
so what we can do is we can just say
that and I'm not sure of the best place
to do that is here but it is I mean this
is an unsigned integer so we could say
that if width is zero or height is zero
that's the problem all right so we
definitely shouldn't resize in that case
but also we shouldn't resize if width is
greater than like a maximum frame buffer
width which at the moment not something
that I really nor we could just say
static Const like you and 32 T you know
max max frame buffer size of 2's on the
school for that max frame buffer size
and we'll maybe write like oh maybe we
want like a 16 K frame buffer as the
absolute largest I'll write a 192 for
now which is like you know fairly large
I don't know if we'll ever have anything
above that I mean the GPU probably
supports 16 K or so
but for now we'll write this the reason
I'm doing this kind of in a temporary
way is because we shouldn't be looking
at the GP like we should be looking at
the GPU code capabilities to get these
values out we shouldn't just be
magically hard coding them like we are
here and that's part of the reason why
it's all weird anyway with greater than
frame buffer size and high greater than
R at frame buffer size so if we're
outside of if any of these values are
outside of this range then we basically
don't want to do any of this
right so we could just write return and
that would be at the end of that I will
actually write the a core error here I'm
not sure if this should be an error I
may be able to make it a warning and
we'll just write a template to resize
frame buffer to and then we need the
width and height so with oh my height
one just to log it so this should be hit
if we press Windows key D so if I try
and do this it will tell us what's wrong
and this is like more of like a capsule
situation where we're actually handling
it at the frame buffer level here
instead of doing it back out there and
with the I'm GUI giving us up we had
negative size for some reason what if I
hit widows key D you can see my desktop
does get shown and if I bring back hazel
and look at this you can see that it's
wanting us that we attempted to resize
frame buffer to something completely
ridiculous so this is just a way for us
to know what's going on because we are
taking an unsigned integers not signed
integers so we lose that kind of
negative value possibility okay so
that's something that we need to kind of
handle I don't know if that effects
there anything else I mean I guess it
does because if we look at the camera
controller and we look at the honorary
size event our aspect ratio gets
completely messed up the cameras
projection gets set wrong this is not a
good good thing to do because anything
here is in danger of being wrong now the
reason why I might be permissible is
because realistically what this does is
require to matrix this doesn't really do
much I mean it sets the aspect ratio and
the cameras projection but that's kind
of it and what will happen is when we
restore the window I expect us to get
another you know viewport panel size
change which will mean that it risk it
restores it back to a decent value so
whether or not you choose to handle this
is up to you
um you could say something that if the
viewport size does not equal viewport
panel size and we could say viewport
panel size dot X is greater than zero so
it can't be zero and it can't be less
than zero and the viewport panel size Y
is greater than zero then by doing that
that stops this from happening at all so
if I put a breakpoint in here probably
not now and I'm also curious to save
this if this actually gets triggered if
we minimize because it might but it
might not because we're actually end up
pausing our application if we don't
minimize which I think means that this I
am GUI function is just not going to get
called at all anyway if we go back here
and you know K so this hasn't been
called yet so let's hit what is key D
yeah that that absolutely did not get
triggered at all even though if we put a
breakpoint here yeah okay so this isn't
running at all so this must have
happened in the inner in a situation
where maybe we minimized but it wasn't
aware that we did that yet and so we
still had one more call of this code
which then queried the available content
region and in that fail so it's a bit of
a timing issue that we need to think
about all right anyway now that we've
done that let's move on I guess today
will be more or less like a code
maintenance episode I have to be honest
I I don't even know what to do next
and that's why I mean I always said that
these are gonna kind of feel like live
streams because the thing is I'm very
quickly realizing that I don't like this
whole artificial game engine series
thing I think that it's um I think that
it's not realistic to try and teach how
to make a game engine from scratch I
think that it's just it's too hard you
know it's kind of like if there was a
tutorial on how to build a car from
scratch or like a real engine you know
like you are either gonna build
something extremely simple or you're
just simply going to gonna have to cut
out certain like a lot of realistic work
right and maybe if you did actually
build an engine from scratch by yourself
and you had that kind of completed and I
don't even know what how I don't even
know how you can call that completed
because game engines don't really get
completed you know every large game
engine in the
world that has that that kind of has
been developed and like it has not gone
bankrupt
people are still developing it people
are still working on it
so it's it's kind of like a
philosophical thing that I end up
thinking a lot about because I just end
up being unsure about what I'm doing
with this series because it is kind of a
big undertaking and it's very difficult
you know if you look at something like
handmade hero which is probably one of
the only things that is similar to this
it that that's a bit different because
there is still a tangible product which
is a game and games do get shipped
eventually surely they might get updated
forever like Minecraft but they still
get shipped whereas a game engine is the
technology used to build games that is
never really finished the only the only
time that that gets finished is if
people stopped working on it because
they move on to other things right
that's it it's not because it's done
it's because it gets abandoned and that
that is a little bit worrying because
that means this series will ever end but
also I feel like you know maybe 3d and
all of that stuff aside I have basically
taught people how to how to actually get
like an application stack with events
and lay the fact lay the foundation for
like the really the quite bare bones
base or core of a game mansion and I did
that in like kind of a step by step
series which is why I made this kind of
decision to make this into more of like
a live format thing and I have been
toying around with the idea of making
this completely live streamed on Twitch
or something like that so we'll see if
that happens because I think that and
then maybe like putting together like a
highlights video for YouTube which
contains all of the actual programming
things and maybe not so much the
thinking about what on earth to do
sections so that's still a possibility
and I will give that some more thought
before I do anything but my point is
that you know we're at the stage now
what we have to think about what to do
and there's infinite directions we could
go in if I launch this you know our
whole like the thing that I want to get
to and I think I wanted to actually have
this done by the end of the year was
getting to the point of being able to
make some kind of 2d thing with hazel
right
at the moment everything that we see
here is being rendered I think in real
time meaning that like we literally
every frame just submit a bunch of quads
and we draw them and you could make a
game out of this I've talked about that
before as well we could you know even
tried making a game which I regret
telling to be honest but anyway you you
you can you can make a sort of game from
here right because you have the ability
to draw graphics you could make a class
you could take more of an
object-oriented approach make a class
that is an ante that does something give
it some behavior give it some rendering
commands and you've basically got a game
especially something simple like space
invaders or snake or Tetris even you
know even games with slightly more
complex logic you can do all of that
stuff but we're not interested in that
we're interested in being able to do
this kind of stuff without the use of
C++ and without the use of recompiling
binaries all the time that is slightly
more difficult and that's but that's why
we're going so if we take a look at this
and by the way you can hide this tab bar
not sure if there's a way to
automatically launch it in that state I
think if we just exit and we go back and
it will be in that state just because
the I am GUI - ini file remembers that
stuff yeah there you go
but I don't know if there's a way to
force it to only be in this state not
that that's really required because we
might have multiple scenes open because
it's like a scene kind of panel where
our our scene tab bar but anyway so to
move on with this what we probably want
to do is I think think about an entity
component system and that's something
that that's something that's the next
big thing I think we're going to start
with and then once we have that we can
start adding components to entities
because once we have entities and we can
and we can actually talk about well we
can start thinking about what what
functionality does entities should have
and how to add that like in a modular in
a modular iswe using components when we
start thinking about that we'll need an
energy component system and once we have
that again you know I think at that
point we can probably start thinking
about making more tools to actually add
components to move entities around to
make a static world that is not
generated procedurally and then once we
have that and we want to start creating
behavior for
entities then we can probably integrate
c-sharp so that's kind of the rough road
map for how I see this I might make more
of a formal video talking about this
with like a diagram or something because
I know it's very open-ended and I also
literally just thought of this now but
that's kind of my plan so I do want to
eventually make it so that you can click
on these things but at the moment that
would be a waste of time because if we
think about it what is this what is this
Red Square it's literally just a quad
that we're telling the renderer to
render every single frame it's not it's
not a thing it doesn't exist it's a quad
it doesn't have any behavior it doesn't
have any it's just it's just some pixels
that were coloring in what we need to do
is create is actually make an entity out
of that first that has a transform that
has a size that has like you know some
kind of sprite rendering component
something that actually brings it to
life and then from that moment on we can
actually create a better system to be
able to for example select and do stuff
with it as well as being able to create
new squares right if we if we talked
about that now if we said hey let's go
in and make a button that says add
square we could absolutely do that we
could absolutely add some gizmos and
ways to move it using the mouse and
resize it and do all of that stuff but
it would almost be a little bit of a
waste of time because what we would be
doing is manipulating the renderer we
want to manipulate the game state we
want to manipulate the idea of a scene
and we don't have any of that yet so
that's and there's no point in writing a
scene until you have an empty component
system because since we're going to be
designing this this game engine with an
entity component system a scene is
something that contains an entity
component system and might contain a
whole bunch of components I mean
entities don't really exist in any
component system because MCS are made up
of components and really all that entity
kind of is is probably an identifier but
anyway there's a lot of stuff we could
think about and a lot of stuff that I
don't want to do now but my point is
that you know this is the state that
we're currently in we're probably going
to start integrating an two component
system and I think I've talked about the
fact that I want to use entity for that
or ant en TT because I could
my own but I don't think it like it's
honestly not gonna be as good as aunt
and it's very popular and used by a lot
of people and I you know I might have a
separate series on how to write an
entity component system for those who
are purely interested in learning how to
do that but I would rather use amps and
just get on with this and actually
create a workflow rather than spending
another six months writing a complex
empty component system which in turn is
probably gonna be less supported and not
as good as pants so as a solo game
engine developer I think that a smart
decision to make is knowing knowing
first of all what area you want to
specialize in and then also making sure
that you delegate you know as much work
as possible into third party code where
possible based on licensing and stuff
like that because so the area that I
want to specialize in as you guys
probably know I love graphics I love
entering that's the code that I want to
write by hand I don't want to use
something like B GFX for that because I
love graphics but NT component systems
they're pretty cool but they're not
something that I want to spend half of a
year on especially because I'd rather
get this thing working you know what I
mean and also because I want to sub
making games with this engine and it's
hard to do that if we actually actually
do this like handmade hero where
everything is written from scratch so
we're not trying to be that and those
are my kind of I guess reasons for my
decision anyway so we'll do that next
time we'll wrap up
we'll probably wrap up this video not
not immediately now but we will continue
we'll probably we'll probably start with
ant or entity whatever you wanna call it
next time and we'll make a same system
and all that stuff and we'll plan it and
I'll talk a bit a lot more about that
then but what I want to do now since we
still have some time is I want to check
out the possibility of just basically
cleaning up some of this code because
there's a lot of stuff that I'm not
particularly happy with and there's a
lot of stuff that's been merged in and I
just want to basically do a code review
of the whole engine so I don't know if
we'll do a code review of the whole
engine today because it's not like
it's not that big actually I'm used to
working with hazel dev which is
significantly larger but still you know
let's less maybe start with and and by
code review I don't literally mean like
just looking at the code and just seeing
if we can you know if you know either
fixed bugs or rewrite certain code I
actually want to look at the usability
and what the API provides and see if
there stuff there and this is just gonna
be a commentary so if you guys are
interested in that and stay for the rest
of the video if not then thanks for
watching hope you guys enjoyed it don't
forget to hit a like button and I'll see
you next time alright so let's start off
with application now I want to actually
talk about a few different things here
and maybe it's even worth me doing the
code review in a separate video where I
actually just look at every single line
and and also talk about where it's gonna
go from here so a lot of this stuff
let's start with base a lot of this
stuff is stuff that I didn't add so this
what I see here which is a little bit
overkill but what I see here has been
added by a pull requests and it's fine
that it's been added because it's
definitely not doing any harm is
definitely making this code a little bit
a little bit more intense but the reason
this exists is is basically a whole
bunch of platform detection using
predefined macros I'm not the biggest
fan of this for a few reasons so what
this is doing for those of you who are
not who don't know is they're basically
checking for compilers compilers on
various platforms define their own
symbols whether you like it or not so
for example is simple sauce is this a
super sauce compiler is this a C
compiler what version of this table has
C++ compiler is this what platform is
this you know stuff like that they just
have basically built-in definitions so
in other words if I take this card and I
compile it on clang on Linux or whatever
it's going to not have the win32 macro
defined out the this symbol defined even
though windows and M SVC will actually
have that defined so if we take the
predefined symbols that certain
platforms and compilers have and I mean
by platforms I mean compilers on
platforms
is always the compiler providing these
symbols if we take that then we can
deduce what environment we're running in
automatically without having to define
things out front so for example you can
see that if when 32 is defined and when
64 is defined then we define each their
platform windows if it's not then we
actually just put in a little compile
error here that says that x86 bills are
not supported that seems reasonable so
in other words you need to be if you're
building on Windows then you need to
make sure that you're building on a
64-bit environment with a 64 bit
compiler it makes sense right if win32
is not defined an apple is defined or
Macintosh then target conditionals is
included which not 100% sure why but
target OS Mac exists on all the
platforms so we must check all of them
to ensure that we're running on Mac and
not some other Apple platform okay so a
whole bunch of code once again to detect
whether or not this is the iOS simulator
whether or not it's an iPhone it's a Mac
OS and you can see we're even defining
ages at platform iOS which is not even
supported right now which is why there
is an error here which is good I
would've been upset if there wasn't it
if there wasn't an error because we
would leave leave people to believe that
we support that if we turn which is not
great same with Android stay with Linux
you guys get the point now the problem
with this and the reason why I don't
like this necessarily is first of all it
takes it takes control away from the
person writing the build system and it's
kind of relies on certain definitions to
be defined on certain compilers now yes
certain compilers on certain platforms
do guaranteed that these things exist
and that's fine and I don't doubt that
this code works what I don't like though
is first of all in order for these
symbols to be defined based on H has to
be included everywhere now is it
included everywhere
the answer is nor it is I believe
included in the precompiled header it's
not included in the precompiled header
okay that's even worse because as you
guys probably know the precompiled
header is included in every single CPP
file at the moment
now hazel dev as a more complicated
example does not include the brigham
part header in every TV file the reason
is we some third-party libraries are
being compiled as part of the default
cook as part of the core hazel module
and we don't want to inject them with
third part with our card and so because
of that we just disabled precompiled
headers for those individuals say Burpee
files in which case again we wouldn't
get the age set platform definitions but
we don't even care about that right now
the thing is because the precompiled
header does not well I mean it might
actually because I think a log includes
base so I guess I'm wrong but you guys
probably are starting to see hopefully
that it's a little bit flaky it's a
little bit dirty
right dodgy because because because you
know we might decide oh we don't want
log
we don't want login they pick a
bald-headed changes too often it's long
down builds let's get rid of it and then
suddenly inadvertently we've lost base
and actually you saw that immediately
this changed this used to be included
and then it it was no longer included
right now it is again because we've
removed log now why would removing log
remove ages at platform windows that
doesn't make any sense does it and yet
it does so things like that decisions
like that are so important to think
about when you're working on large
complex projects because if you don't if
you don't scrutinize every bit of code
that you write and I'm not telling you
to do this because if we did this we
would get no what I'm just saying that's
like a lot of decisions and the way that
you make those decisions they actually
might have more of an impact than you
might think and specifically for
platform macros for macros that are
absolutely vital to the core build on
the platform my favorite way of defining
that and as you can see for good reason
hopefully I mean I'm it's fine if you
have a different opinion than me I'm
just telling you about my opinion is
defining them in the compiler
preprocessor because if we stick ages at
platform windows into here then every
single CPP file that gets compiled in as
part of this project right in whatever
configuration we set up which would be
all configurations it is 100
gonna get this right whereas this is
slightly dependent on again base being
included in every single CPP file and
not only in every single CPP file but
before everything else right because
you'll also probably notice that if we
do this right look at that
it's gray you know what I mean like it's
a little bit it's a little bit flaky and
we're trying to go for not flaky in it
would like with hazel so anyway that
hopefully this is what I mean by code
review like I want to actually look in a
skirt and as I cut a little bit more I
might do so in a live stream so that you
guys can act so you I said that you guys
can ask questions I actually the more I
think about it the more I really want to
convert this series into a live stream
format just so that we cannot just that
I can interact with you guys a little
more because I feel like that's gonna be
helpful I feel like you know building a
game engine going forward is a lot
better if people can actually first of
all help me by correcting things or by
making me think about things that I
probably didn't think about when I'm
running certain code but also so that I
can answer questions and help people a
little bit more dynamically in a more
interactive way so do let me know what
you think about that I might put up a
poll or something a bit later just to
get a just a little bit more opinion
from more people and stuff but anyway
this stuff is fine and again you know
the this stuff does really have to be
the first thing you do because after
that you can see even in this file it
gets used right so platform windows if
that's the case we have HC debug break
which just will break the compiler at
that particular line of code if it gets
hit you know with Linux we're including
signal and doing we're just raising a
signal which is fine and that's what
we're doing assertions being enabled I
don't think we support sessions I don't
think we support assertions with nor
arguments do we and I remember I spent
about a day figuring out how to do that
this is why I'm not the I'm not the
biggest fan of like very attic macros
and just
macros in general to be honest I mean I
used them a lot because you kind of have
to and they are useful I will admit I'm
not like not scared to death of them but
I'm not the biggest fan and the thing is
I don't know where I'm gonna let's go
here actually I know there's a bunch of
stuff well it doesn't really matter
where we are but you know we have a core
assert here if I just assert false I
don't think it's gonna let us do that
it's not right because it needs another
argument I don't like that I basically
not doing that that's stupid and I
didn't like that so in hazel dev I just
made a version of this macro that does
not take in arguments and that is quite
complex I'm probably not going to
implement that now but that's something
that's kind of like a to do so I'll
actually add it to do here and I'll
right make this macro able to make this
macro able to take in our arguments not
even sure if that makes sense I don't
even know ok whatever the point is that
we want and no arguments except for the
condition obviously it's def condition
ok a bit fields whatever that's fine
bind event function we'll keep that in
here for now because I think card
depends on that and then we have scope
and ref hmmm now as it stands right now
we're using this I'm not too concerned
about because scope is relatively simple
and straightforward which is just a
unique pointer this there we're
currently using shared pointers for
reference counting which is the the main
kind of way of managing memory in most
game engines but this is something that
will get changed in the future because
like an Hazel Dell for example we've
switched to an intrusive reference
counting system and that's like
important for a number of reasons but
this is not going to be here to stay
which also like the API that I've used
in hazel dev is also slightly different
to the one that we have here so that's
kind of important anyway point is that
this is this is something that's gonna
change in the future
now I think that's that's the entirety
of base today so this could see
basically a full engine review at this
point it took like no time at all right
entry point yeah I think that probably
not worth reviewing the rest of this
performance profiling is is good key
codes I think this has changed as well
it's now an enum class I'm fine with
that
[Music]
realistically speaking that's it's
better to have it this way than to have
it as a bunch of macros even though we
still have these macros you know mapping
to specific things and I don't know I'm
sure what we have this to be honest if
we have this maybe just because of
legacy reasons because we didn't want to
break code that may have been written
not sure but either way that should get
removed one of the reasons why it's
important to have this stuff is because
well first of all when we move this
stuff into c-sharp it's gonna have to be
some sort of enumclaw like it's not
gonna we cut we don't have macros in
c-sharp and having a local constants or
like weird static constants is not a
good way to go either so this is a
better approach and there's no real
difference about that these numbers are
a little bit dodgy like here at least
you know we had glf w3 and but now this
is kind of like a little bit random I'm
not sure like again this is something
that will probably have to be tested on
different platforms because they might
report different key codes and of course
I'm not you know I'm not sure it will if
we are going to use gfw for input
forever because we might want to deal
with like windows raw input for example
and a few other things that I need to
think about so so yeah anyway there's
still a lot more engine code to review
one of the things that caught my eye
there was the whole vertex array
situation because and I mentioned this I
don't know if I mentioned this one
writing the vertex or a thing but
it's really how should I put this it's
really vet x-rays don't exist on any
other rendering API
apart from OpenGL vertex arrays are a
little bit of an anomaly right because
they don't really make sense like vertex
buffers vertex that is vertex and index
buff is sure that's a very common
graphics concept vertex array is not so
much vertex arrays are things that can
contain potentially multiple buffers but
the real thing to bed XR a is contain
apart from the fact that they can be
linked to an index buffer and all that
stuff is the actual layout now the
layout is very heavily and should be and
I definitely agree with like DirectX and
also Vulcans design on this you need to
tie your vertex buffer layout to your
shader because that is you know you
provide a buffer on the CPU that you
eventually give but that you eventually
store in GPU memory in your vram and
then you have literally written a
program that needs to take in that
buffer at that exact same layout because
it all it says is binary data and does
something with that buffer if they have
no concept or validation between them
that's just asking for trouble right and
that's the case with OpenGL and that's
one of my least favorite things about
OpenGL so vertex arrays I'm I have not
decided what to do with them because
they are vital for India for they are
vital for OpenGL you can't get around
using vertex array unfortunately you can
have a global vertex array and then a
buffer and then a vertex buffer that
gets rebound every time into a new
vertex array and a whole bunch of other
stuff okay so you can basically get away
with not using vertex arrays or whatever
but you do you still kind of probably
should use them maybe if you're using
OpenGL so another another good idea is
potentially because you can see by
looking at this code that it's mostly
just I mean it's literally layout that's
it I mean sure we said it we said an
index buffer and it kind of takes
ownership of it same with a vertex
buffer we kind of push back for a text
buffer into this but I don't think
there's ever been a case and correct me
if I'm wrong but everything
ever been a case of us using more than
one vertex buffer in innovate x-ray I
think it's always one because I don't
think I have ever in my life apart from
just to test out whether or not it works
I don't think I've ever in my life used
or seen multiple vertex buffers in a
vertex array I I have heard that maybe
there are some cases in which it would
be better to do that but usually the way
that you do this is you just have one
vertex buffer with like whatever data
you want and it's all kind of
interleaved and that's how you deal with
it I do think that in some scenarios it
might be more cache friendly to maybe
have multiple vertex buffers if you only
need to read a sub selection or sub like
some kind of subset of attributes but
I'm not a hundred percent sure about
what that's about and I have not in my
experience done that so what we could do
is just collapse basically a vertex
array into a vertex buffer for OpenGL
and this is more something we need to
think about when we introduce other
rendering api's but ultimately if we do
that if we collapse that into vertex
buffer then every vertex buffer will
have a vertex array if you're using
OpenGL and that's kind of that so that's
something to think about as well anyway
hope you guys enjoyed this video let me
know what you thought about all the
things I kind of talked about what we're
gonna do next episode this was kind of
more of a review discussion episode I
mean we fixed I guess the bug with the
frame buffer and the I M GUI situation
but ultimately we spent most of it doing
a little bit of a code review there's a
lot more I can say and there's a lot of
a lot more things that I want to fix up
but ultimately I think we'll leave it as
is for now and next time we'll we'll
start with the entity component system
and we will also probably end up facing
the engine as we go but I hope you guys
enjoy this video if you did please don't
forget to hit the like button and also
help support this series on patreon.com
force - Letourneau huge thank you to
everyone who does help support this I'm
really excited for the future to be
honest I can't wait to get into actual
you know making that 2d workflow for it
which basically you could say starts
next episode with the HD component
system and maybe I'll see you guys in
even like a live format so thanks for
watching and I will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]